good evening
it's really heavy
um good evening and welcome to the
central area planning committee meeting
at modern district council on thursday
the 29th of june 2020. i am councillor
carly mays and i am chairman of this
committee
this meeting will be strike streamed
live and recorded and by being present
in the meeting you are giving consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
i encourage members to keep their
contributions clear and concise
when invited to speak remain seated and
speak clearly when speaking refer to
gender papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
where appropriate
item two um apologies for absence do we
have any tara
i think so
full house
excellent
thank you um item three we move to sorry
um we move to um recommend that the
minutes of the meeting the central area
committee held on the 16th of march are
approved as a true and accurate record
these are presented for accuracy only
i so move do i have a secondar
thank you councillor shaunicy
are there any matters
arising or can this be agreed by a cent
thank you
declarations of interest
members are require are reminded that if
they are required to declare any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests which they know they may have
in items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
they are reminded that they will need to
repeat their declaration at the
appropriate point in the meeting and
leave the room if required under the
code of conduct any unforeseen interests
may be declared similarly at the
appropriate time
are there any dis
disclosables
thank you
oh swiftly
uh right we now move on to item five
application 21
0 0 5 four zero
out the land at blackwater trading
estate the causeway malden malden
northward on pages 11-40
the proposal is for outline planning
permission excluding landscaping and
appearance
um
excuse me
we are only looking at access layout and
scale for the erection of warehouse
units class b
with associated vehicle parking and
servicing
this has come to committee for
determination as a major application
the recommendation is to approve
um
subject to the applicant entering into a
legal agreement pursuant to section 106
of the town and country planning act
1990 as amended to secure the planning
obligations and subject to conditions as
detailed in section 8.
the officer report presenting our report
this evening
is anna
tashloglou
thank you chairman
so
the application site forms part of black
blackwater trading estate
and it is located at the easternmost
part of the estate uh south of bates
road
the site covers an area of approximately
2.1 hectares and currently comprises
hard which fear to be largely used as
open storage area
outline planning permission
which as stated already with matters of
appearance and landscaping reserved for
future consideration is sought for the
erection of just under 10
500 square meters floor area of b8
storage and distribution buildings with
associated parking and turning areas two
temporary buildings partially occupying
the site
these two here are supposed to be
demolished
as noted uh it is noted that the
proposed development has been amended
during the process of the application to
allow a 20 meter gap
you can only hardly see that here
um
from the existing flood defense along
the southern boundary um with hybrids
creek
this has resulted in the reduction of
the amount of floor space of
approximately 1 000 square meters
access to the side maybe i'll use that
plan
is again from an existing um
vehicle network
of courseway here this is all one way
one way into the side and one way out to
the side
and in terms of parking provision it is
stated that one car parking space will
be provided but 150 square meters of
floor space
including five percent of parking spaces
designated for disabled people
floor plans have been submitted and
indicative elevations and for the
proposed units
these are the floor plans for unit a
smaller units b to e
floor plans of unit f
and g
these are the existing streets in
elevations
again these are indicative only and this
is what's proposed indicative
these are the floor plans and the
elevations of the two buildings that are
to be demolished
some photographs of the site this is the
application site
as you can see
it's mainly hard surface surfaced
with open storage
uh this is the access to the site
this is brooks brothers
travelers
uh and aldi
and this is the
uh
existing
should be pedestrian cycleway
along the northeastern boundary of aldi
um
this is north west of the site heybridge
creek to the south east and
this is a view from the side towards the
west which is the
exit actually of the site
so having taken all material planning
considerations into account it is
considered the proposed employment land
which falls within b8 use class would be
compliant with the stipulations of
policies e1 and s5 of the ldp as well as
policy ca2 of the molding and habits
central area master plan on these basis
and subjects subject to the imposition
of an appropriately awarded grampian
condition to secure the provision of an
off-site cycleway
and food way
connection the principle of development
is considered acceptable the development
is located within flood zone 3 however
this is a designated employment site
where the positioning of this type of
this type of employment usage has been
has been considered acceptable
following revision of the layout and
amount of development proposed
an objection is no longer raised by the
environment agency in
relation to flood risk and accessibility
to the flood defenses the impact of the
development on the highway network and
safety is considered acceptable and
adequate off-street parking provision
has been provided a taking and
monitoring fee for the travel plan will
be secured through a section 106
agreement
the development subject to the
imposition of condition a condition
restricted restricting the operating
hours is considered having an acceptable
impact on to
residential amenity
as this is an outline application has
already been told the details of
appearance and landscaping of the
development are to be dealt with under a
future application
so in light of the above it is
considered that the proposed development
subject to conditions and developer
contributions as set out in on pages
31-37 of the agenda is considered
acceptable and in accordance with the
development plan
thank you
thank you
before i open the floor could you just
explain what a grampian
condition is please
of course yeah through determine so a
grumpy condition is a condition that
imposed for works that they are off-site
basically outside the
application side and they are works that
are considered
necessary to be
to be completed
before the erection of the development
and the development would not be
considered acceptable without the
completion of these works
thank you
members
i open the floor
councillor none
yes thank you chairman um
as you know chairman this is a new award
and mine
so i'm grateful to you for allowing me
to speak
um as far as i'm concerned this is an
industrial development on an industrial
site
and so i don't particularly have any
major problems with it there are just
two issues
that are going around in my head at the
moment the first is about flooding
and i hear what's being said about flood
mitigation
but this is
right on the edge of haybirds creek
as far as the site is concerned it's the
nearest to the river course
so i do remain concerned about uh about
flooding heybridge creek has become
towards its end something of a ditch but
originally it was a main channel and
it's still got the potential to be a
main channel with climate change
the other thing that i'm pleased to see
however in the report is on page 29
and on page 37 at 30 and 31
the archaeological conditions
although it's rather disappointing that
the only periods that have been
highlighted as potentially uh
um uh that there on the site are roman
and 19th century this was a public area
during the 18th century uh and it's uh
according to some uh potentially the
site of the battle of malden as well so
i'm really pleased that the
archaeological condition is is placed so
my views are that i um i would be very
supportive of this thank you
thank you before i come to councillor
spencer um
can that be uh can that condition be
extended to include the 18th century
sorry chuck
i was simply making the point that
there's an archaeological condition
which is really good
but whoever has highlighted that
condition presumably the county
archaeological section have simply
regurgitated the potential for roman
remains and 19th century we won't know
until the conditions completed
but i'd like to think that there's a
wider context there than that thank you
chairman this is normally the response
that is received at this stage
from essex county
council historic the historic consultant
is based on um
desk study desk-based studies no i mean
once the archaeological condition has
been implemented and they've done all
the excavations then we would know
whether there was anything further
this is a sufficient condition to
capture yes it's okay thank you thank
you councillor spencer
hello thank you chair um so what i'm
going to say now isn't really relevant
to whether or not we decide to approve
this but it is i think a really
important point to make and it's
regarding the grampian condition
so i'd like to draw members attention to
section
5.1.8 of the officer's report and around
halfway down that section
it is noted that the development of the
blackwater retail park has realized
necessity of an off-road connection for
pedestrians and cyclists and a
pedestrian cycle path has been secured
through approval of application and the
application number is given
along the northern boundary of audi
now this is um was the retail park
application to to explain
whilst this path appears to be fenced
off and made of materials that are not
pedestrian or cyclist friendly it is
noticed that compliance of the of the
development with the approved plans is
secured through condition five it is
noted that the council is aware of the
breach of condition and therefore it is
in its power to take enforcement action
should this be considered expedient but
i just wanted to make the point here
that if we think about that for a moment
in practical terms if it isn't enforced
then we're actually what we're asking
for here is a path that won't be of very
much use so it's really to reiterate the
point that i think that needs to be
enforced um councillor edwards and
myself did go down to the site today and
look at the footpath and cycle route
that you have in the picture and it's
completely unusable and fenced off in
its current state
um i draw attention to this for a couple
of reasons at section
5.1.9 of the report the seriousness of
this is apparently making this point
first of all the developer clearly isn't
keen on putting this um
in place that's the first point i want
to make and i'll explain why i'm making
that in a moment the second part
says exactly why we've got the grampian
condition the lpa therefore considers
that the provision of a pedestrian and
cycle link connecting the site with the
existing cycle and pedestrian network
which would also provide easier access
to public transport is necessary to make
the development acceptable in planning
terms
and sadly um
i've already i've only been as you know
in office for a couple of months and
i've already come across another site
which michael johnson is aware of where
it's a housing site where a condition
was in place that access should be an
access point should be put in place
before the estate was built sadly it
wasn't properly done and now isn't
enforceable and it isn't isn't possible
so why i'm not blaming any officers for
that at all because i know you've been
you know you've really been faced with a
mountain of work and you've had you know
they're very short staff numbers and i
appreciate all of that
but what i want to say is that i just
wanted to make the point in summary it's
absolutely crucial
that the completion of this particular
route under this grampian condition is
monitored and put in place and that we
enforce the previous pathway that also
wasn't enforced and i just think if we
if we're serious about climate change
and sustainable transport it's
absolutely essential thank you very much
thank you thank you i'll come to you in
just a moment yeah um through you
chairman yeah i mean
first of all in relation to the grumpy
and condition they wouldn't be able to
carry out the works without implementing
the food waste cycle way first so that
would have to be done
before any works start on site even the
demolition of the two temporary
buildings
and also we've we've been in discussion
with um michael johnson who's uh leading
on the enforcement team there is an
enforcement case and
i believe if this application if
generally but even more if this
application has been approved tonight
this will be looked at
as a matter of urgency
yeah
councillor edwards
thank you madam chairman
um i have a few questions i'm
uh we did indeed have a look at it today
um the first thing is apart from the
footpath the access by road is through
the grounds of another company
behind it so if you go long drive along
brooks brothers
you go
in front of another country which is on
the left-hand side
and
i don't know if you can see it on the
to access it you have to go across the
yard of a
second company which is behind brooks
brothers
if i got that correct that was right
wasn't it i think so yeah
and
to get on to the
where the location is
there was there's no access road was
what i'm trying to get at and even on
the other side
we can't access it either we tried to
accept we couldn't
and i know there's a fence across some
of it and some of it's got storage on it
but
the difficulty was
the access for vehicles and also the
footpath because we weren't sure where
that was even going at the end of the
audi footpath there's nothing there that
was the first point
the next point is
whilst we were standing on the
hillbridge creek side
right across
is um
the development it's trying the name
um right across and we were standing on
the creek listening to the fortress
trucks on the existing warehouses and
the noise going right across
to the residence on the other side of
the river were surrenders
and one of those factories one of those
warehouses had a big sound barrier when
i say sound barrier it must have been 20
foot tall
to stop
there was a big
high sound barrier to stop the noise
from the warehouse going across to the
houses but in this plan there's no sound
barrier
and those warehouses are actually nearer
the development than the ones where
there is a sound barrier if that makes
sense um the other thing i noticed i was
just looking for electrical charge
points but i think
oh they are in there there are just been
going through it trying to find them
but there are no solar panels and solar
panels for a warehouse flat roof would
be ideal in terms of the climate change
that's happening so there's no solar
panels although there is electrical
charging
and
that was it actually thank you
electrical electrical charging points
are actually a condition 14
and i'm i'm not aware because it's not
contained within the ldp we can't
actually enforce solar panels at this
point hopefully that will change in the
future which is really disappointing but
we can only appeal to the
um the applicant to perhaps consider
that very strongly
um
yeah correct so
um to determine about access and
footpath first of all access
just to point out that whatever is
within the blue line is owned by the
same uh applicant is the same applicant
so although there is a
um because i visited the side there is a
fence along here this will have to be
removed for the development to be
implemented because the access which is
through here this is the entrance to the
site will go this way maybe you can see
on this plan this is the entrance and
this is the way out
so
all of the all of the access will be
within the applicant's ownership
all the um
in relation to the food path
the existing
foodway cycleway which is not made
properly and is also fenced off is along
here
so what we are asking is a connection
from this point
to this point
so this this is all tarmacked at the
moment obviously there's no
good way or cycle way that's why we are
asking for it
and so i think that's covered access and
food path and in relation to the
residential development battle rise
which i think it's the one here
um
there wasn't an objection in easily from
environmental health
because they wanted to operate 24 hours
uh 24 7. so they've accepted to reduce
the hours from um 17 or
seven till eleven yes condition sixteen
exactly and that was considered um and
that was considered acceptable uh by the
um
environmental health officer
there is quite a significant distance uh
bates road is here if i'm correct
and
no you're right there isn't a condition
for an acoustic barrier to be installed
and
it has not been requested by the
environmental health this side was
always supposed to be used for
industrial purposes and actually this
part of the site is already used for
industrial purposes but as an open
storage rather than one that is enclosed
within the building and
i mean
we as officers didn't see any particular
reason for us to impose a condition for
a barrier an acoustic barrier
but if you think that's
that's necessary and um
to make the development acceptable
condition for it is that conditional or
does it have to go
do you wanna michael
that's right um no i think
it'd be very difficult when we're
talking about something like a bund
a very substantial structure
um normally subject to
detailed
analysis of noise and wind direction and
that sort of stuff here
um
it couldn't be a matter that we could
reasonably apply and defend
um
committee at this stage
if members wanted to go that route you'd
have to defer the application for
further consideration and then
discussion with the applicants but i
mean it's such a significant matter
yes yes yes of course now we'll go to
council but yeah i understand what
you're saying um but there are acoustic
barriers already there they're not buns
they're it's a wall
they're not thick
so it's just been put up as a and it
must have been a condition they'll have
that in the first place
that's my thinking if i could come back
i think you'll find that that barrier
has not been put up by this site that
was put up by um green recycling the
other side and that was a requirement of
their condition on a previous yeah on a
previous application
because it was a sorry management
because that was an industrial
business going on there because of the
nature of their business but the
forklifts do make a noise we stood there
and listened to them
and i'm sure the residents over the
river would hear it because it would go
straight across the river yeah can i
just sorry madam sir can i just go back
to
the question of access by the road that
was one of my questions which i didn't
actually ask it is the same owner who
owns that present company that the part
and the access is going to cross their
own land to their own warehouse thank
you just want to clarify that thank you
uh can i go to castle lagoon thank you
chair um there's a couple of things i'm
concerned about and the debate has been
um has been very
buoyant so far
um i take what councilman says about
being an industrial area which it is um
but i'm still concerned about the flood
risk down there and i noted that the
redeemer works that they'd saved would
be one in 100 years um to reach that
um
i'm not sure whether that would be the
case for the way that global warming's
going but you can only look on the
statistics that are there but at five
point three point two
um to pick up on what councilors
basically said i don't suppose the
environmental officer lives in battle
right so the the he's not gonna be
hearing that that noise but it talks
about um intensify the use of the site
will result in increased vehicle
movements and noise generation and also
potential noise from plant installations
something going from seven o'clock in
the morning till eleven o'clock at night
would definitely have a detrimental
impact on people's health and well-being
i feel um and i'd concur and i feel that
we should
it might be difficult to do but if it
takes we have to defer the application
to to look at some form of acoustic
screening planting hedging trees
whatever's out there because it's
difficult to do doesn't mean that we
shouldn't do it because we're talking
about the impact on people's lives and
noise as i will know is a
problem so
there's a few things here
yes the conditions may
pass it through
what the planning
mppf says and also the policies
but when you look at it from a moral
perspective about getting a decent
development that serves the community
going forward that keeps people safe not
only the people working there but also
the people who live around there um i
have great concerns about it as it
stands so i would very much support
deferring and looking
at what we can do to protect the people
in in battle rise and those areas
and also make it look a bit more um
i know we haven't got the reserve
matters an appearance yet but i think
they'll be fundamental because downs
road is going to look over it
and then people walk along the prom and
they come here for the tourism
yes you've got an industrial area but
let's try and make it as nice as we can
thank you
thank you um
councillor um
11 o'clock at night
our residents are going to be kicking
off very hell
because 11 o'clock at night
it's all quiet sound travels overnight
you know you've got to do some tips
i mean environment agencies aren't
stipulated because they're not living
there
you know at the end of the day it's like
yeah as long as it's not on my doorstep
but we all know from greens how noisy
that is
because of their equipment and if this
is an industrial state at work i can't
imagine who's going to be working till
11 o'clock at night
but at the end of the day you need to
somehow condition that we have set
attenuation
because it is literally right opposite
all of those houses
i'll come back to you
i'll come back to you in a moment
because i'd like to hear from
um council sean c and then council
spencer again
uh
thank you pat and chair uh two things if
i may um
i'm also concerned about this um the
noise problem
um and i do know
that the um sound barriers i'm not
talking about a bund i'm talking about a
proper
um tall as councillors would say they're
about that wide
proper sound barrier along there
um it it you know it it would be the way
to go should this um should this go
ahead um that was the first thing i
wanted to say
um and uh the second thing is um
i realize that solar panels cannot be
forced
um on anybody at the moment um but i
would like to think that the idea of it
um as as as has been mentioned already
has been minuted please and
so i would be grateful if we could check
that chair thank you
yes absolutely um
council spencer
hi thanks thanks chair um i just wanted
to agree with what's being said about
the sound barrier problem and
interestingly i was speaking to an
environmental health officer here today
with regard to a problem we've got
elsewhere with an industrial site and
they were saying that haybridge is the
most you know difficult place in the
district in terms of the industrial
residential mix because because of how
it lies and i think you know it would be
good to look at this um as a possible
condition for this so the residents know
that we are as a council acting in their
interests and i think i wondered if a
site visit would be possible for members
obviously i'm very new so i'm not quite
sure about that um but i think you could
see it would be it's easy to visualize
the
the
the distance of battle rise
from
from the development which i think you
can't necessarily see just by looking at
the meters you know it's it's looking at
how close it is to that development with
regard to the water in between because i
don't think the meters fully captures it
but that's just
um to back up what what councillor
edwards and councillor lagoon have said
thank you thank you um i'll go to
council swain and i'll come back to you
councillor
thank you madam chairman um
yes on this
um
20 metre
gap that they have now
made this presumably is still remains
the companies or the
the company's property right up to the
edge of the sea wall
um
if it can't or part of it can't be so we
say conceded as public property for
a footpath and cycle away
um
and i don't see why that should
necessarily create a problem for the
applicant if they're not if it's not if
it's going to be left as a as we say a
blank area but
um regardless of that
um
uh and this question of some noise
barrier
um it seems to me there is an
opportunity here along this whole
stretch
to combine a decent interesting
cycle away footpath
with greenery with environmental gain
with a
perhaps um a physical barrier of some
sort of a fence
acoustic fence and plantings um
to mask the noise that will and
inevitably go straight across the um the
water to um
to haybridge so i i think i don't know
whether this is something which can be
dealt with a detailed stage um but i
think we need to
make some sort of um
uh what we say
condition that
about the nature of the
footpath cycle way that uh and and about
um
using
a green barrier but for noise
attenuation the the other thing is on on
um
flooding um given it's so low-lying
they're lying
um
is this particular development making
additional provision for
a flood attenuation and or is it relying
upon the existing
[Music]
existing arrangements in this general
area
okay
um
pretty chairman yeah i hope i i i'll
cover everything so
and
so i'll start from the last then because
a few points have been raised about
flood risk uh
no attenuation new at any attenuation
basin is proposed within the site that's
not a proposal the 20 meter gap here
of undeveloped land is for the
environment agency to be able to access
the site to do improvement works along
the flood defenses if required in the
future because it will be required in
the future so that's the purpose of them
of the gap and conditions in relation to
sustainable and drainage uh system has
been imposed and has been requested by
the local flood authority this condition
22 so all the details of how water
surface water will be managed inside
um will be secured is secured through
condition 22.
um
in relation to
the
public footpath
there are plants within the north key
development plan for a foot bath to run
along heybridge creek this is outside
the site and
i don't know if if you i don't know if
you could see from the photographs maybe
here
this land here
which is a little bit of green before
the hebrews creek this is on the lower
ground so this is all within the
applicants whatever you see on this side
this is the application side this is
outside the site so any footpath would
be
outside the application side
we've considered that for the purposes
of this application it would be more
important to achieve a connection
and through the existing cycle and
foodway network um in order for future
um employees being able to access the
site with sustainable modes of transport
um
in relation to the
noise
barrier uh
i think that's
i mean if if members are minded to defer
the application for this to be
discussed with the
applicant
from my understanding
just planting
is not enough as an acoustic barrier you
would need something more than just
planting
and because if it was only for planting
we would we could have dealt with that
under the landscaping condition
but i don't think that's sufficient for
noise attenuation purposes
and
you would need to consider if this is
something that we need to discuss with
the applicant the visual impact as well
as um
the
noise impact only on one last one last
thing um
this side you we need to consider the
position of the side so the battle rise
is here if there is a screen along this
side you would see that
the position of the application site is
kind of like screened
by the green recycling center so
if there is an existing i have not seen
it myself but if there's an existing
acoustic barrier here
maybe that would be sufficient to cover
any additional noise um from the um
increased activity on site
um but yes again if if you consider that
this condition would be necessary and
you consider deferring the the
application then that's something that
could be discussed i'm going to um
what am i going to do
you can come back yes
when i've been around there there
doesn't seem to be much of a scope for a
path outside
this area and it would seem to make
sense for this access
access road for environmental agency
purposes to be used as a
cycle and footwear
um
as far as noise is concerned and i don't
see why
an acoustic barrier can't be put up
there and and uh asked for
um i seem to i think i might that when
we had a
application for
another sort of open warehouse
development a bit further around i think
we did have a provision or a requirement
for some acoustic
barrier because it was directly
opposite from hall road
yes of course yeah through ceremony we
for
in order to impose a condition we need
to have in mind the six tests
this is
we need to consider that this is a site
that is already used for industrial
purposes is used as an open storage
and so
as you already know there are six tests
for the conditions one of them is to be
reasonable and necessary so
somehow we need to justify
that there is a need for an acoustic
barrier um
on the side
i mean considering the existing use of
the site i'm i'm not quite sure whether
that could be
reasonable to be asked but again
we could talk about this
okay i'm going to come to uh counsellor
bill then
no i'm actually going to go to a council
heard who hasn't spoken as yet then i'll
come back to you if that's okay
so counselor hasn't spoken thank you
chairman i'm just on page 21 at the
moment uh
5.44 it's just really a question the the
car parking spaces that they're they're
providing a 107 parking spaces and it is
a
uh it's an old itch of mine presumably
these are going to be the larger parking
spaces on here rather than the the
smaller ones
they're 2.9 by 5.5 yes they're 2.9 and
those are the large ones
that's fine thank you
um council bale then councillor lag and
then can and i'm going to finish with um
cancer edward oh i will finish with my
vice chairman
obligation
to basically
give was sending community
benefits as he
further
not far from where greens is there's a
path comes across
the creek there from whole road
it comes towards
that state
now i'm thinking
as a community asset
if we could extend that path instead of
going across into petrol whatever it is
continue along the sea wall where
and it could actually join up with the
shopping center
which means you wouldn't have to go down
the causeway
basically be joining
yes
and then also i don't know if you've
seen it
down at mill beach and you talking about
sound attenuation i don't know if you've
all seen it they've got like the
alternate slats
yeah so
still get the wind in that through it
but it does
protect sound wise something like that
would be probably more
visually
attractive
thank you
thank you for that accounts counselor
thank you thank you jeff let me come
back yeah
picking up what anna said
i don't think we measure an eggs with
eggs and are you a professional officer
and i'm just a nobody but it is a i i
can't see how it would be unreasonable
because the land is not being used for
the purpose of which the applicant wants
to use it for i.e in close warehousing
offices etc running machinery that they
don't run now
albeit so there's other things so i
think it's really quite fair and
reasonable to ask them to look at some
sort of sound attenuation uh methodology
for that area um because i think it's
really really important that they that
is installed in some form and because it
is going to be running a long time and
it is going to be loud you know not i
work in an industrial area and the noise
is produced
a lot and you've got to try and protect
people's quality of life
so i propose that we defer
um this application until conversations
i don't know the terminology mr johnson
but defer it um until we can actually
is it i like that thank you
deferred until we come about attenuation
okay um can i can we just hold that one
there because i'll come back to you i
just wanted to go to councillor shaunicy
and then i'm finished with councillor
edwards um and then i'm going to come
back to you councillor
bouncy through me
the pathway using that as a pathway
i think i think yes
i think
[Music]
isn't something we could condition just
like that i think that that would need
to be explored
i know i mean and then again um if we're
looking at a contribution if it's
outside of the site there'd have to be
justification for that
uh they'd have to be
normally these are things which are
secured through the local plan and any
you know ancillary documents that we do
have where it can give us the
justification for something which fits
in with a sort of wider plan
i'm not sure if that's something that
we've looked into um necessarily as we
probably didn't feel that this
application triggered that but that i'd
have to refer to my colleague anna
uh thank you through your chairman so
yeah we
given that this is outside the
application side
he should be if we're looking for a
contribution it should be
a planning obligation
and at the moment we have secured the
monetary checking and monitoring of the
travel plan but to have a contribution
towards the provision of a food path
it would be
a planning obligation and again there
are three tests for planning obligations
they need to be
relevant to the scale and size of the
development so if we ask for something
it would need to be relevant to the
scale and size you should make it should
be necessary to make the development
acceptable in planning terms
so it's whether we consider that
otherwise the development would not be
acceptable in planning terms so that
that would be another consideration and
it should be um reasonably uh related to
the application side
so
again we have to have all in mind and
any planning obligation would need to
meet these three tests
um
so again we need to be careful as to
ah there was no no necessarily no can i
come back to one point that's business
yeah thank you um about my scenery uh
just to confirm that there is a
condition
and
condition
[Music]
with me
17 that
requires any if if there is any external
plans to be installed or machinery they
need to provide us with details
just to confirm that
uh councillor shawnee
sorry chair council edwards did give way
to me of which i thank him um
i would just like to to give a word of
caution um due to something that
has been happening uh since i was
elected as a district council virtually
on west ward it is essential that we get
this right now it's essential it's
essential that we get the sound barrier
that is needed to protect the people
across the creek
because on west ward due to a previous
planning
decision and it doesn't affect any of
the people here on the front bench this
evening
which was a few years ago um
councillor heard and i have got a huge
noise problem
due to a bad planning decision uh for
some people that have um really
that are really badly affected by
motorbikes um from the um
uh i can't remember the name of the
motorbikes now
over the way and and i think the houses
were overlooked initially because they
are behind foliage there
um
so and and it it it's a dreadful problem
at the moment to get things um you know
sorted out and and reversed it's really
you know almost impossible to get
planning decisions reversed
unfortunately so
just a word of warning this has to be
got right
right from the beginning
otherwise we're going to have a similar
problem again as counselor heard and i
have on westward thank you chair
i'm going to come to you in just a
moment
councillor stilts yeah it's just a very
quick question is there an s106 on this
um only for
through ceremony it has not been signed
yet but yes there is an agreement from
the
applicant to
contribute towards a travel plan taking
and monitoring of a travel plan
so could
the uh idea that councillor bill had be
put into that s 106 agreement
if we consider that this meets the three
tests that's the only way it can be
secured
okay councilor edwards then i want to
come back to uh councillor lagann
thank you welcome chairman thank you let
me come back
i just got three little questions
[Laughter]
um
sorry
i know this is a major application which
is being really quite you know
um there's been mention of this acoustic
barrier outside of the development i
don't understand that it has to be
inside the development not outside it's
where the cusick barriers are all ready
for the
whereas is already there they're inside
the development not outside but
that aside can you please just go back
to the slide
the view of the fencing
um that one
not the other one
no i got the wrong one
just there you were talking about
putting in a footpath well product 45 is
there we walked it today
so it goes from behind that uh site
to across to battle rise so and that's
people
of w-45 but it stops
further up so that comes to my second
question because you want to join it up
with the pathway
by the side of audi
isn't that part way the property of audi
so how will that development another
development
um
get involved with a with a with a
a repairing or a pathway that belongs to
someone else thank you
uh three chairman yeah sorry
um
first first point uh i don't think that
it was
that it was um
mentioned that an acoustic barrier would
be outside the side if if you this if
it's been decided by a committee and a
grade that um an acoustic barrier will
be installed that could be within the
site that could be secured by condition
it doesn't need to be a contribution um
about the
uh
this part yes this is as far as i'm
aware is owned by aldi it was before
part of aquila site but it's been sold
off as far as i'm aware but what we are
asking here
um as part of the grampian condition is
not for them to reinstate that
this this will be part of the
enforcement case because they there was
a condition for this path to be done
under
under certain standards so that would be
dealt with separately under enforcement
and enforcement case what we are asking
is that the developer connects
this to the side yeah
okay
um councillor nan as board member did
you want to is there anything further
you wanted to add at all no i think it's
been a very thorough discussion thank
you
um
councillor lagan uh you made an initial
proposal
um
they were just so that everybody is
aware there are two bits i i feel that
we need to consider one is deferring
this application which i think you were
going to put but also um the possibility
of a site visit
um
council lag and would you like to
well um thank you chair thank you for
letting me come back and i agree with
cancer now that's a very um
deep and careful debate and i think
listening especially what counselor
shaunicy has said so we've got to nail
this um
i still maintain the the the
proposal that i raised earlier on about
deferring um the application currently
so that we can look at what um noise
barriers options are available to this
and look at how we could condition those
do we have a seconder for that proposal
yeah we have lots
more information yeah
i'm i'm gonna go with
um castle that's fine thank you but i
i'm i'm open to a site visa but i know
the area really well so i'm not you know
i don't need to see you okay does
anybody but does somebody anybody else
want to second a site visit
yeah i have a a seconder for um
organizing a site visit its council
seancy thank you very much
um all in favor of both of those
uh
abstaining or against
of the site no the deferring
okay deferring is everybody and the site
visit
um
three to one two three four five six
seven
in organizing a site visit
that um you can end up with a very
few people actually determining because
people aren't available all the way
through so i mean it there is that as a
as a caution
um and i wouldn't have thought it should
be necessary in this case
well it's been agreed that we will have
a site visit seven uh seven to three
three one two three four five six seven
oh and myself eight
yes mr mr johnson
sorry yeah through your chair so
we're agreeing to defer
for a site visit but specifically for
the purpose of
if the noise can explore
the noise
potential noise issues with the and in
conjunction with the footpath with the
footpath yeah sound barrier yeah those
two elements
those two elements right just just so
we're quite clear
are we up
i just
they're coming down
no
okay thank you um thank you members um
can i could i just stress barrier rather
than bund thank you
okay um let's move on to um
item six which is um application
four
2200
four house plum tree house london road
malden something's flashing at me uh
which is eastward councillor swain's
ward uh the proposal is for a single
story front side and rear extensions
with additional dormers to the front and
rear roof slopes as well as a new porch
and changing of windows and doors
this has come to committee as a result
of a calling by um councillor spain on
the grounds of policy d1
uh the officer presenting is jay dallas
miss ellis would you like to present
your report just
sorry
it's actually salford it's not an
eastward property i beg your pardon
thank you
but it was called in by an eastward
member
okay thank you
thank you chair
uh the application is for a single story
front side and rear extension with dorms
to the front and rear roof so
the application is also for a new
portion changes in fenestration
this application is a resubmission of
the application twenty one
zero one one zero zero slash house
which was previously refused on the harm
to the character and appearance and
would be an unable form of development
due to the side extension
they have sought to overcome the reasons
for refusal by reducing the roof height
by 1.6 meters on the front extension
the roof lights have now been removed on
the front roof slope
the front extension has been reduced in
depth by 0.8 meters
the lean-to roof on the side extension
would be 0.6 meters higher than on the
previous application
dormers have been added uh
there'd be french french doors have been
inserted on the rear elevation to
replace the previous pose full height
window which you'll see in the previous
uh
in another slide
and the french doors
have been inserted on the side to
replace
previous proposed patio doors
here is the proposed site plan the
hashed areas are where the extensions
are being proposed
here are the existing floor plans
here are the proposed floor plans so the
red bubbles is their fenestration
changes french doors um
they'll be french doors instead of four
windows and patio doors
uh here are the proposed second floor
plans
yeah second floor plans
existing elevations
the proposed front and side elevations
with the outline is showing where the
existing garage is currently
proposed rear and side elevations
so the change of fenestration from
window
to french doors on
the top
elevation and the bottom one is showing
the fenestration from the patios to
french doors
here are site photos on the rear
elevation facing the north
side photos of rear elevation
from the south and the rear garden
uh rear elevation facing north and then
the side where the proposed extension is
to be situated
and then the front towards the front a
street scene
based on the existing garage
and then the north side
and the garage again
and then
photos of the entrance site in the site
and out of the site
and then the street scene looking to the
south
facing
what's opposite the site and looking to
the north
uh the application is up for refusal as
it is considered the amendments made
with the current application have not
overcome the pre previous reasons for
refusal
therefore the proposed extension to the
front
by reason of its position height and
depth would result in an overly dominant
addition
it is also considered the dormers
by reason of its design would result in
harm to the character appearance of the
existing dwelling and locality thank you
chair thank you
members
thanks for spain um yes thank you madam
chairman um
well
there obviously have been discussions
between the applicant and officers but
um
according to the officers so it does
hasn't resulted in a
a satisfact application from their point
of view
um
but this has
happened two or three times and the the
reason that i've
um
referred it or called it in was because
of the um
the nature of the
reasons given for refusal in relation to
this particular location
um
as i mean as uh council of logan
observes technically it's in south wall
um but it's directly opposite it's
surrounded by fields
um and on the other side you have the
whole string of um
uh of bungalow type houses down london
road
um
and um
i find it difficult to apply some of
these terms we all use them about
incongruity and um
impact and neighborliness and this sort
of thing we've used those when we've
made recommendations at town and parish
level um but um in this
in this instance um i wanted uh to
uh what you say ask the officers really
to go into greater
um
depth as to why they find um
the this particular one to
affect the character of the area and the
little street scene and um why is it is
incongruous in any way
um given its actual position
and um
these matters are dealt with under
policy d1 which
uh concerns design but when you read d1
it's really
um geared to talking about new
developments and in fact new significant
developments really and it's quite
difficult to actually
relate the terms of of um d1 to
such an application as this
um in fact in one of them seems to be
particularly relevant about
number 10 about making better use of
space
um would actually seem to favor this um
more intensive use of the space
um so
um i
have haven't called it in with a view to
which we say trying to reverse the
officer's
decision well i thought it would be
useful for members for all planet future
instances if we could have some clear
idea of how they apply some of these
um
cons some of these arguments which
essentially come down to
rather subjective judgment
um
well i think you hit the note on the
head counselor swain there is um
he's always argued that design policies
are subjective yeah
but that subjectiveness is based on
an accepted set of criteria
uh that criteria being
in particular the context within which
the development lies here
um you know this is not isolated
dwelling it sits within a street scene
although it is on the other side it's in
a particularly
oddly shaped plot if you want to put it
put it that way but it is still part of
the street scene it is a conventionally
designed house
and
our starting point with any new
development especially when you're
extending existing properties to start
with what is the context of the street
yeah
um
how far are we deferring from or
the original design yeah
methods of scale in terms of elements of
the design is it is it proportional and
related to the building as a whole so
for example if we look at the at the
dormer windows
we've taken the view that given the
conventions of dormers within that
street
these two
dormers are considered to be oversized
and and out of character with the roof
as a whole
we're not saying that they can't be
dormant because dormers are a convention
within the street what we're concerned
about with that is is the scale of of
the dormers so that's taken that's the
view that we take of that others may see
things differently but that's how we
take a view we look to try and maintain
a level of consistency within the street
otherwise
it would effectively be a free-for-all
and we'll be back to those days when uh
individuals can
almost design what they want then you'd
have to question is there is there is
there a need for planning designs in
that sense
um
in terms of the front elevation
the applicant has sought to address some
of the issues they've reduced the height
and they've set it back by 0.8 of a
meter
in the council's view having an
extension on the front of the building
in that way again looking at the
conventions of development within the
street we feel that it is out of
character
it is
i mean if for example front extensions
extending
beyond existing properties in that way
it was a feature of the street um then
we can consider some variation of that
we're more likely to be amenable um to
something of a particular scale as long
as we felt again it was proportional
yeah proportionally in terms of its
ridge height that was one of the reasons
why the ridge height was reduced by by
by
one meter because effectively previously
you you had more or less a two-story
extension at the front that's not
typical convention
um in a dwelling like this so again
that's the view we've taken
we've just don't feel um and which is
articulated in the report that it's
actually gone far enough so that's
that's the view that we've taken towards
this application thank you chairman
would you like to come back
um
first of all i don't think the building
has got much character
inherently it is a bit uh vamshakal
anyway as far as i can see um the other
point is
i take it officers haven't actually
counseled against having dormer windows
in the up second floor
um
which was um
i mean i assume they haven't actually
said that
it's a bad idea to have dormer windows
in this particular order
how's the lagoon
thank you chair um
his personal taste is personal taste
isn't it um
when i looked at this obviously because
i know the property well
um
as you can go out more than it's on the
right hand side as you go down under
road and there's two properties there
there's this one and there's another one
on the other side they're very different
to what the actual other side of the
street is although one of the bungalows
at the very bottom of the south has been
completely renovated and doesn't look
like
the what the house used to look like um
it's just different you know
when i looked at this i'm thinking it's
it's a house on a rather large block
that has quite a main road under road
going through it that sort of set back
on its own and
this to me actually sort of balances it
up a little bit you know and i think the
applicants have gone and looked at you
know taking the advice from from from
the architects and yourselves and
done some changes that
they're here before us today and it is a
subjective nature but i think that when
you look at that road because of the the
the the country nature of the road as
you go down on the right-hand side and
the difference i don't know whether
those arguments about you know the
street scene imposing and changing it
radically would be that
uh radical um house and families road
built in mr um
capon's house radical absolutely when it
was done it must be the 60s 70s
yeah and it's like it sucks out like a
sore thumb and it adds something it
really does so i don't see that this is
something that is really dramatically
different it's a very big big building
you know it's the applicants want to
make it and balance it up um and i'm i'm
actually in favor of the application and
credit should go to the applicants for
for taking the advice because i think it
would yes it would be big but i don't
think it would be
overbearing and overburdening if it was
on the other side of the road however it
would be a completely different story
because it wouldn't match the street
scene but that's how i look at it and
i'm minded to go against the
recommendation to refuse
thank you um i'd like to go to council
spencer then councillor stilts and then
councillor edwards
yeah i'd agree with them councillor
lagan having visited the site today it's
just a completely different property
from the rest of the street scene
already
it's completely out of character with
the rest of the street and it stands on
its own it's hardly visible when you're
driving through to be perfectly honest
and i think even with the changes
proposed it's not going to make it
hugely visible but i agree that actually
the drawings that we're seeing here
to my mind
actually would make it blend in better
than it does now because it's a really
ugly house actually at the moment
yeah
probably not so long
but what i'm trying to say is this is i
would commend the applicant that this to
me looks like an improvement on in terms
of the visual amenity so i i can't yeah
i'd agree with councillor lagan thank
you uh councillor stills
yeah just one question really on page 48
7.2 you've got a statutory consultant
which is the tree consultant
and we're talking about a cedar tree in
a palm tree and then in
5.71
you talk about this tree but i don't see
any conditions for this tree being put
in
no that wouldn't be because it was a
refusal of course
sorry
i'm coming back on that can we put a
condition in from the tree if we were
mindful to pass it
mr johnson yeah thank you i think in the
in the report it does say that
um if it were minded to be approved then
a condition
of that nature
thank you um councillor edwards
thank you madam chairman actually cancer
lagging has actually already
mentioned the fact that it sits back it
does sit back a long way
and the houses on the other side of the
road actually come up to the boundary
pretty well of the uh
pavement i think there's a payment along
the un the front gardens whereas this
house sits
quite a way back
and the extensors on the front will
won't come up to the boundary it comes
halfway along and you can't see them
because of the trees so i agree with
cancer lagon and others thank you
okay um do i have a proposal from
anywhere i'm on the floor
councillor lagan
go for it
i never really know how to phrase these
things properly but um
i propose that we
uh do not accept the recommendation for
refusal
um but prove um
the
[Music]
plans submitted before us now okay we
just need we need to know the reasons
not to approve
mr johnson no i think sorry through you
chair um i think i kind of know where
counselor um
lagan is going i suppose a justification
would almost be the opposite of what the
reason for refusal with
thank you
is that that yeah
would be the extensions of the front
together with the front door windows
where is the design height
would benefit the area
it wouldn't be a dominant um
addition it wouldn't result in
demonstrable harm to the character
is in line with the existing dwelling
and locality and is in line with
policies d1 and h4 of the mdlp
full stop
correct okay could i have a
seconder secretary
thank you councillor shaunicy councillor
stilts um madame chair can we also put a
proposal in that there is a condition
on the tree worker please
and then obviously there will be the
standard conditions that will go
there's nothing else that we need to
consider
okay yes that will be included as as a
condition
what
can that be seconded counselors shauna
say thank you
um okay
all in favor
okay well no we'll do the um application
first to approve those are those in
favor of approval
one two three four five six seven eight
and
those against
one against
abstentions
and one abstention
um those in favor of the additional
condition regarding the trees
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
thank you very much we will now move on
do we have miss matthews
i hope so
um we'll move on to item seven
um
application twenty zero zero eight five
six
the diversion of public footpath number
fourteen
um hazely and public footpath 41 malden
um
is this in south ward
it's in westward okay i've got i've got
where i've got westward i've got this is
cancer shaunicy and heard um the
diversion the proposals make their
diversion permanent and if no relevant
objections are received to confirm those
diversion orders by modern district
council as the competent authority under
section 257 of the town and country
planning act 1990. this has come to
committee as the application is not
delegated to officers to decide
miss matthews could you present your
report
this
yes
i've got a little assistant there
excellent thank you
i wish i can't see
[Music]
which currently cross
the western parcel of the
um
which forms part of the
um
suburb
so um
i think on your screen there should be a
plan showing
um
and
if you
scroll to the next screen it will show
you the outline permission extended
development and the third
i think um let's show you the
layout for page two of the western
possible which is
only construction
and
i managed to overlay the two but um
the um footpath does go right in the
middle of that so foundations of women
have been variety for
residential development over the the
footpath but this but this is a separate
additional process that the developer
needs to go through formally
and diverge and close and the existing
stretching the footpath
and so the
the diversion route is to go
through the
site their land so along the edge
um in north south direction and then
following the southern boundary of the
um
bishop
so the
the the this process has been
administered by this kind of council of
highways on our behalf um and they have
that they have carried out to further
part of their process so the
the district council to make the order
following which there will be a period
of such a period of consultation
and
and then
um if any objections are received then
they'll need to be considered um before
the capsule decides for them to confirm
so it's
that's where we are in the process
but there
is is this is something that was always
expected to happen and needed to happen
um
um and it came a bit longer than
expected to come through because i think
there was some random ship issues but
then now being resolved and yes so
that's that's the
um
thank you
thank you
um
i've just got one question um which was
about the ramblers representations are
you able to give us any information on
that what what their representations
actually were
um i
don't know exactly what they said um so
the process has been carried out so far
in the informal consultation process
with the caterpillar
just to see whether there are likely to
be
objections received um i can
i can only assume that because it
because if the
footpath their ownership process has now
moved to this day that any issues or
concerns that were raised were not um
insurmountable or there weren't any
issues that would prevent the order
being confirmed at the local at
okay thank you very much um i'd like to
go to um councillor nunn and then
councillor edwards and then councillor
swain thank you chairman um well it
sounds to me like this is um something
of a fighter comp play
and
i'm really disappointed by that because
footpaths are a really important part of
our landscape heritage
and some of them have been there for
centuries
and i'm being told but in this
presentation that the reason it needs to
be
redirected is because the development is
going to build on top of it
well there are other developments that
have occurred in malden in the past and
recently that have actually incorporated
the line the original line of the
footpath
and i know it sounds a bit contradictory
with them with a modern development but
at least the integrity of the footpath
has been kept
so i'm really disappointed by this but
it sounds to me like uh
we're not going to really get very far
if we uh
if we put forward a proposal to object
to this
uh thank you um i don't disagree with
you actually i think you're absolutely
spot on um councillor edwards
thank you alan chairman it's not a
question i haven't got a question
regarding the footpath itself
per se but
rather i was under the impression that
exists county council manage
public rights away are we being asked as
a consultant or do we decide something
that actually is managed by us it's
county council i'm not quite sure if you
could clarify that point for me please
thank you mr johnson
i knew this would come up through you
chair um i think first i'll say i'm no
expert in this
um but my understanding is um
the public right of ways exercise
through the town and country planning
act
so on that basis um is within our remit
to um
to in a way sort of be the custodians of
the process
hence our involvement
county councils effectively act as
um
i don't know our operators in terms of
how the process works in itself
uh but at all the various stages it
still has to come through the local
authority
especially in terms of the final
ratification
i think as catherine pointed out there
are several stages to this
there are four stages you've got what
they call the informal stage
that's the stage in which the
significant consultations had been
carried out with all the interested
parties
um including the parish council so
i'm not sure if any of yourselves are
aware of that process having been
carried out through the
parish council
all the immunity groups ramblers society
and all those sorts of people would have
been consulted and given the opportunity
to make their representations
those would have been taken on board
and as catherine mentioned has there
been any adverse elements to that
we either probably wouldn't get to this
stage or it would take us much longer to
get to this stage
this is a made order stage this doesn't
and again it's it's an administrative
process
this does not say that
the prowl can be built or that there's
an agreement to an alternative route
it's just part of the process which
initiates the third stage
which is a confirmed stage but at each
stages there are consultations again
with those interested persons
um and then then in the fourth stage is
what they call the certification stage
um
but even then that goes through checks
and balances so that's sort of how the
process is
so the fact that we
agree
this stage which then moves it on to the
next stage in itself does not
give the final say to
the uh prowl or or any alternative route
thank you mr johnson uh coming back to
what uh councillor nunn said so would
the some of what he was saying um
be a relevant objection that we could
actually levy against this and actually
reject this
um application
because we've either got to approve it
or we've got to reject it
through to you chair i'm not quite sure
what uh if counselor nun had given an
objection i i think honestly counselor
none was unhappy with the process
because it almost seems that their fate
had come play
given the fact that development had been
approved
um the land parcels had already been set
um the existing prowess
goes through the site as catherine
mentioned
um and there is almost no alternative
hence the fatal complaint comment if i'm
interpreting without putting words into
thank you chairman yeah without putting
words into counsellor nun's mouth um
i
get the impression that
um
rather than
moving this um
proud that it is actually
uh
diverted around the houses and and
basically follows almost the existing
path that it does
or something along those lines i was
expressing disappointment yeah
because it's an important part of the
landscape heritage the problem i've got
with this is that if there have been
other consultees
we don't know what they've said
it's not in the report
there is no comment
from conservation from archaeology
from the ramblers association as you've
said i don't know who's been consulted
over this
and so um
i
find that it's not a complete report
really
thank you
um i'm going to come on i'm going to
continue around if i may uh councillor
edwards and then councilman swain
oh i beg your pardon um
council
thank you
chairman
and
as far as the landscape
is concerned this is sort of being
obliterated by the development of the
this part of the garden suburb
um i see no value in trying to
follow a footpath route through a
housing estate
um i assume this diverted path would be
entirely within the
the um estate so to speak under fringe
of it um and perhaps uh miss matthews
can confirm that it doesn't
that it is or within the um
gertrudish we say of uh what was it
countryside properties
um
uh and won't you doesn't depend upon the
private um
access
on the west side
um
and is it actually intended to be part
of a green belt round the fringe of the
estate which seems to be an improvement
thank you i'm not sure
miss matthews
yeah sorry
um yeah so the
can hear me guys i've crossed a second
um
yeah so the the
diversity route would be
through a landscape belt which is
proposed along with the southern bound
at the site and if um any more mindful
assistant can let's bring up the um
the a method layout
for phase two you can see along the
certain boundary um uh a landscape build
with a little path
through it and so that would be the new
route of the footpath so it would still
be and so it would be along the edge of
the government and right next to the
fields um and the rural area countryside
beyond the golden suburb and
that that's what the um
the diabetic route and the proposed
alternative route um
it's going to be so then we've got
the details of phase two then there'll
be
phase three which is submitted in the
reserve
um
but
the permission for phase two has already
been planted
um
without
the developer being unaware of any need
to
i think that opportunity has been has
been lost um i suppose the
quite a long time ago so
at that time
maybe um
member's views were
different and that's worth pointing out
that there is a similar level or
comparable
version that was required for the
eastern parcel and so there was a
footpath that went right across diving
across the field that is now
um
being um built on and and so that was
diverted just around the edge of the
field a similar
similar scenario to to this and that was
um
by um by the
planning community in district cattle um
and that issue
about trying to retain it
um within the development of energy
levels was raised at that time
yes it's whether this is actually within
a green
fringe to the estate and
as a further point or would it be
actually fenced off from
from the um
from the development
no
there's no certainly no um
proposals to fence it off now so the
footpath and the landscape
that's okay stripping along this
boundary would fall apart past sort of
the resident development
um
and those of which along the south
southern boundary uh
the lower scale
dwellings and
um
does that
answer your query yeah okay thank you um
councillor bill and then councillor
seancey
this redirected path is going to be
interconnected with that state and it's
not just a
standalone it is actually going to be
connected to other parts
that
whatever period or
barrier between the houses and the
landscape and the footpath
the recreational side of
living in
thank you
uh yeah mr johnson
so through chair and just draw members
attention to
uh 3.3 of the report
um
where it states that condition 21 of the
outline planning permission requires a
following
and that is for
um
prior to any occupational development
details of any public footpath diversion
within the relevant parcel lease or
where shall be submitted to an improved
by local planning authority
etc etc and it states the the relevant
act the fact that there is that
condition ties it in with the
development it ties in with the
responsibilities of the developer in
providing and maintaining
that footpath
the details for that application as it
then goes on to say in 3.4
were submitted
in
2020 so that just shows how long this
process has been going through how
thorough this process is into in
ensuring that the fourth path all the
relevant persons are notified and fully
aware of its implications
thank you chairman thank you
um
is that okay thank you um councillor
sean c then cancer lagan and um
councillor heard thank you
um
thank you chairman
um i totally agree with um councillor
nunn's views on this i mean it is a fate
accompli i really don't know why
we have got it before us tonight and
why have we this one and not the
previous one mentioned by ms matthews on
phase one
um there just there just seemed to be
really an inconsistency there
and also
um
there are one or two
members on town
um planning here
but i am pretty sure that this issue did
not come to mourn town council as a
consultant
thank you thank you thank you uh
councillor logan
oh it's a comment really more than um no
it's not common it's a moan and i think
that
it's we're so easy just to give stuff
away
you know you you you might be a footpath
and it might be able to redirect it but
it might be an important thoroughfare it
might have some memories for people who
used to walk down there with a dog or a
family member or whatever who like to go
through that area so i'd like to see a
bit like the old bridal ways you know us
to be an officer to be a bit more
detailed in the the will of the members
to go you know look what what what the
opportunity is there an opportunity to
work with a developer to try and maybe
keep some of these things rather than
losing them because we've got these
massive estates going up all around the
area
yeah
if you're going to do that in hearts and
keeper and as as councilor may says add
to it put the south one in but say to
the developers all right let's see if we
can do a plan it's not hard and
complicated and it is quite nice and you
know to be able to walk through some of
those areas because i know the area like
the back of my hands i used to play down
there as a kid so i can't do it now
because i get run over but um yeah i
just i just feel we just give stuff away
too easy you know the small stuff is
really important to people
so yeah it's a moan and a whinge but not
particularly anybody and it's a done
deal racism has to happen so
thank you uh counselor heard
thank you chair um
well i think that uh i mean i speak i
speak as a ward member
we're not taking anything away from
anybody i mean
if i lived in any one of those houses i
wouldn't want somebody marching through
my back door
and through my garden quite frankly what
we're talking about is a re-diversion
and for those who want to walk they can
walk
if it was retained as it was it would
lose the views and it would lose
the
the part that had because you wouldn't
be able to get the view if you walked
along there you'd be looking into
somebody's uh
backyard so i don't have a problem with
this and i'm pretty sure it did come to
uh to town but it was for information
only
thank you okay members um i think we'll
go to a vote um
councillor uh council spain
can i propose approval of the um
diversion yes yes you might do i have a
second
thank you council i heard
um all those in favor
one two three four five
six on all those against
one two three four and i have to say
myself five because i feel quite
strongly about that um so that's um it
is approved um although we're not very
happy about it
thank you very much um for your time
this evening there are no other matters
um
that
are urgent that need to be dealt with
thank you for your contributions
good night
thank you
someone said something to me
sorry i know i suddenly only did that i
thought there was nothing else to be
done
it's a really
heavy point of it
you